salut tout le monde si vous voulez louer
le studio sf pour faire votre propre
podcasts ou pour objet d la qualité de
votre podcast c'est possible écrivez
nous à sans filtre podcast at gmail.com
vous venez ici le service et tout
compris vous avez la vidéo vous avez le
son qu'on vous donne suite après votre
enregistrement
yann nicol qui va être là pour vous
servez pour vous accompagner dans cette
aventure
le studio sfr on s'assure que la qualité
était petit mal à tous les niveaux et
puis pour ramener votre projet le haut
niveau c'est vraiment la bonne chose à
faire alors écrivez-nous savoir plaisir
de vous recevoir ici production du f
[Musique]
bienvenue sans fil dreux le podcast où
on parle de ce qu'on veut avec nos
invités date cette image qu'on perd -2
me plante
cette semaine le sans-fil présenté par
believe supplément me les suppléments
c'est la compagnie de notre invité
aujourd'hui qui julien aaron qu'on va
parler un petit peu plus tard après que
j'avais fait la plogue pour ses
suppléments blessés personnellement moi
je prenais supplément depuis longtemps
parce que je m'entraîne de haut niveau
depuis longtemps puis les suppléments de
laisser les meilleurs que j'ai pris
honnêtement en plus la plupart de leurs
suppléments sont vegan chacun baissé
killer bce en fait et vegan ce qui est
cohérent parce que la plupart des bce
sur le marché sont faites avec des
cheveux de cochon ou des plumes
d'oiseaux
donc si ces genres de choses que vous
voulez pas dans vos supplément tchéquie
believe c'est vraiment rude
lyon vient de sortir une protéine vegan
est fait à base de pois de protéines de
poids protéines darricau sur les deux
seuls ingrédients leur protéine dates ci
dessus maintenant d'échec je me rendais
ou jeu dans un shaker ce thème
mon but c'est vraiment de la bombe
vous allez rencontrer plus en profondeur
le formateur de believe
on a on ne peut pas de queues de promo
pour le pour le sans fil mais on a jugé
un code promo personnel qui 25 % de
rabais
si vous utilisez le code promo vmp fait
que sur toutes vos commandes on a juste
reçu en interne après le mais fait code
promo vmp pébereau 25% sur tous les
paniers de beaux livres suppléments on
va mettre le lien dans la description et
sinon cette semaine sous le paillasson a
reçu le fondateur d'hommes
lien aaron qui est un ami qui est un
gars vraiment inspecteurs entreprendra
dans le fond c'est que c'est des gens
qui sont souvent séparés espérons qu'on
a adoré parle avec lui en à parlé
justement de sa business
la business des suppléments général ccpo
et aussi ses critiques à certaines
d'elles qu'on peut refaire qui sont tout
à fait légitimes
on a parlé aussi de plein de sujets
vraiment intéressant c'est julien qui
est un gars qui est aussi un peu qu'ils
aiment le développer personnellement qui
aime réfléchir sur les relations sur
l'âme au dessus puis on a parlé de
notamment les manières je me suis plus
cinq façons d'aimer cinq façons 2005
langage de l'amour
ouais c'était super intéressant faites
comme moi réfléchir sur eux
tu es langage de la momie langage de
l'amour qui est
je pars d'un court instant avec 1go je
pense qu'on va sortir de leurs preuves
comme ça me fait penser un peu les
discussions qu'on a eues comme avec marc
qui fit par exemple tu es vraiment des
discussions conçoit développe on a envie
de se surpasser on a envie de faire
mieux envie de se lancer en affaires on
a envie de on sent juste créé un kit
fait que great julie un grain que c'est
un crack eu un grand coeur on a parlé
aussi une autre chose que tu étais pas
mentionné du fardeau psychologique de
son cellulaire ou du travail quand tu
sens que le travail julien qui a eu des
crises de panique liés à ceux qui a
réussi à gérer tout ça on en a parlé on
aborder sur un podcast vraiment super
prodcast sinon vous pouvez vous abonner
à notre page pétri en on est vraiment de
plus en plus sur notre page p tués en
deux mois passés étaient normaux record
en termes de nouveaux abonnés fake merci
à toutes les autres qui sont abonnés une
des raisons j'ai l'impression c'est
parce que après chaque podcasts ont fait
un avec encore moins de filtres ou
encore moins de filtres g oublie tout le
temps c'est quoi le nom qu'on avait
décidé d'un ascète temporairement qui
semblent être restés de façon permanente
mais fait qu'on fait encore moins de
filtres après chaque épisode doit ce qu
on s'assoit d'impy - avec nicole qui les
rend la console on parle à chaud de la
discussion convient d'avoir dans le
podcast
donc ça permet d'approfondir un petit
peu certaines idées si vous voulez voir
qu'est-ce qu'on a pensé de tel ou tel
effort on en parle sur l' encore moins
de filtres puis on veut également faire
des podcasts exclusif de temps en temps
sur la plateforme p tu en sais que c'est
aussi la meilleure façon de nous
encourager
donc le lien votre dans la décision du
podcast et finalement les signaux et aux
mesures pareilles thing abonnez vous à
nos chaînes parlez-en vos amis partager
la bonne nouvelle et bonne écoute mon
podcast ou
[Musique]
julien hier bienvenue au studio sfr
était déjà venu ici j'ai enregistré une
fois dont une fois avec toi puis une
fois avec avec la pointe
je recommande fortement le sud ouest
[Rires]
j'ai acheté 3 et j'ai vraiment apprécié
quelques sonore la console si je me suis
je les fais le temps que j'arrivais chez
nous j'avais des fichiers mp3
ouais parce que parce que toi dans le
fond tout un podcast qui s'appelle le
journal d'un entrepreneur qui est je
dois l'avouer un petit mot j
j'ai une liste mettons de 5 à 6 podcast
hebdomadaire que j'écoute pis la liste
fait une certaine rotation parce que des
fois il y en a qui rentre dans nos prix
fort en sortant prêt à mener toutes les
limites de podcasts que tu peux écouter
une semaine puis le tien men's à néant
que j'écoute à toutes les semaines comme
si j'étais déçu de voir que pendant la
pandémie tu as eu des moments où est-ce
que tu n'as pas sorti mais somme toute
quand ça recommence et de cette semaine
je les réécoute est justement puis en
tant que j'ai un entrepreneur qui
essaient de commencer à naviguer dans
ces eaux là d'hommes tu vas comprendre
ce qui se faisait ça m'aide beaucoup
guide j'en apprends énormément sur c'est
quoi réellement aidé on attend un enfant
un entrepreneur pardon puis qu'est ce
que ça implique m'a dit j'apprécie
beaucoup parce que le bus avec le
podcast vraiment d'être parvenu
spirituel de m'ouvrir de raconter une
histoire mais des fêtes
je pense que c'est important dit il à la
solitude en entrepreneuriat quelque
chose qui est très vrai puis moins de
m'ouvrir à compter mes histoires mais
bonne mais moins bonne je pense que les
gens qui ne le sont pas ils n'ont pas la
chance d'être entouré d'entrepreneurs ou
qui sont des solos benoît mais c'est
bien de pouvoir ouvrir ton téléphone m
une traque audio pippa de sentir seul
d'entendre quelqu'un
three raconter des histoires qui sont
vraies pièces et c'est vraiment pour
appuyer les autres dans leur démarche
puis si on n'a pas besoin de se faire
frapper par une auto pour savoir que ça
peut faire mal
je pense que c'est ce que vous apportez
avec avec le podcast je peux rappeler si
la courbe d'apprentissage certaines
personnes tant mieux timon mon objectif
se soucier d'être importuné spirituel
qu'elle avait cédé tant par son aide
dans vos projets quand même le chantier
ne niveau fermé mais acquis à travers le
podium des gens racontent des deep dans
l'épisode numéro 5 est écoutée sur la
gestion de crise raconte l'histoire de
panique que j'ai eus puis comment
j'avais brimer ma valeur de la liberté
pige mais je mets avaient créé une
propre prison peut-être la chance 3
c'est sûr qu'on va parler de ça parce
que c'est vraiment des choses qui me
fascine dans ton parcours c'est cet
aspect là de montrer les deux côtés
total succès avec believe qui est qui
est accompagné de toasts arte qui rendu
énorme en fait le puits une courbe on en
reparlera aussi
puis c'est je pense que ce qui est
important puisque tu fais bien dans ton
podcast ci de démystifier le travail
d'un entrepreneur puis de permettre de
bien comprendre parce que moi j'ai
jamais pensé devenir entrepreneur de
toute ma vie c'est quand j'étais à
l'école j'étais en littérature je
faisais du sport c'est même pas une idée
qui m'a passé par la tête de créer ma
propre affaire parce que ça m'apparaît
c'est tellement lointaine ça m'apparaît
c'est tellement flou piste est juste
réservé à quelqu'un qui faisait surtout
quelqu'un qui étale en business
quelqu'un qui avertit qui faisait super
qui venait par après ça c'est exactement
ce qu'ils soient cadets prendre
repreneur qu'il avait appris jeunes qui
reprenaient une compagnie mais deux mois
m'imaginer partir quelque chose de rien
mais on comprend le studio aussi comme
exemple le pti on est vraiment allé à
attenton le creusement puis on s'est
réveillé ma mère c'est comme ça et on
est entrepreneur maintenant ben ouais
petits parfois ça va être désir je pense
pas
10 restants pensent d'entrepreneuriat
puis vraiment des mois ce qui me
passionne puis parfois j'ai l'impression
que soit la marque était venu ici
exécuté le produit en tant que tel pour
vraiment d'importance même les abbés
trio est ce ticket sk patience
entrepreneuriat il ya ce qui est une
chose puis il y aussi ces mets ton
témoin réalité avec la musique y est
depuis que j'ai 18 ans je suis
entrepreneur le thé dansant ce qui bouge
et utiliser la musique je vais faire la
musique dans la vie je me suis rendu
compte qu'il fallait que je me crimée
projet que je me crée ma job je me fasse
des contacts se fait que mon désir de
faire de la musique fait que j'ai pas le
choix d'apprendre à être entrepreneur
travers autonome tpiy donc c'est sûr et
puis je pense que ce qui s'appelle
hammam à faire c'est comme si on veut
faire des podcasts ont vu que ça
devienne plus on veut améliorer la
qualité notre affaire on vend notre
propre environnement avoir tout ce qui
l'entrepreneuriat est devenue comme une
nécessité finalement 1 pour accomplir ce
qu'on peut accomplir un titre tous
étaient dessus quelque chose est ce que
l'idée de base commencer une commence
que la fibre entrepreneuriale et nantes
ouest qui se passe qu tripet sur des
suppléments tu t'es dit mais je veux
faire des suppléments ce parce que tu
avais l'idée des jeux de devenir
entrepreneur pis tu cherchais un projet
qui allait satisfaire ce besoin le chez
toi parce que écoute pour un jeu phare
un brief de l'histoire comment ça s'est
passé parce que si vous m'aviez à 23 24
ans j'aurais dit non j'ai aucune
connaissance là dedans je peux
biochimiste suis pas vraiment et je peux
contacter santé canada etc
je suis je suis arrivée là par défaut
parce que j'étais athlète pour une
campagne du supplément dans le temps
c'était vraiment rare si les médias
sociaux commencer puis il ya pas
beaucoup de compagnies comme maintenant
c'est la nouvelle forme de marketing
standard et j'ai passé un an avec une
compagnie purement ni effet que ben
écoute on a bordeaux on a un laboratoire
de production ça t'intéresserait dessus
qu'on parte
le produit ensemble donc c'est comme ça
que j'ai abouti dans l'industrie 10 une
opportunité qui est passé devant moi
puis embarquer dans le train tout
simplement
puis de là est née une passion pour
l'industrie des suppléments peas et
c'est comme ça que séné jeunes tiges
pour ce qui es tu pour ce qui est de la
passion entreprenariale non suis je me
suis jamais dit je vais être
entreprenant un jour si j'avais cette
confiance en moi que j'aurai accompli
quelque chose je savais pas quoi
j'avais 7 reçoivent d'accomplissement là
depuis tout jeune âge très jeune la
gaspésie d'un petit village qui
s'appelle perso je sais pas si ces
clauses derniers mois c'est vraiment à
vous c'est tout petit maître taux de
chômage est à 10% et le revenu familial
est assez bof je sais pas exactement ce
à quoi je n'en serai pas de chiffres
mais c'est quand même une région qui est
assez pauvre qui vit du tourisme donc si
nous on n'avait pas accès au sport
études n'avaient pas accès à toutes ces
choses là y'avait pas l'équipe de
football où j'étais j'ai eu une enfance
j'étais entouré de ressources au niveau
nouveau de l'amour niveau 2 c'est
d'avoir des amis pied c'est sage et j'ai
manqué de rien mais niveau financier
c'est c'était un peu plus difficile que
vous des opportunités exactement si
j'écrivais les opportunités toute ma
jeunesse
toute ma jeunesse puis je me suis dit le
jour joue et adultes peuvent être en
contrôle de ma propre destinée c'est sûr
que je vais vouloir accomplir quelque
chose donc c'est je me suis vite lancé
dans les médias sociaux quand j'ai vu ce
apparaître puis de là est née quelques
opportunités dont celle des suppléments
éventuellement qui était connexes à une
passion que j'avais pour le fitness
donc en plus ils ont fait en sorte que
je me suis retrouvé ici aujourd'hui
puis commence que le job c'est fait de
dire auquel tu fait conjointement un
produit avec une autre compagnie a le
moins je veux travailler sur mon propre
projet c'est sûrement son ma propre
affaire
comment j'ai changé c'est ce bel
événement d'une frustration d'une grande
frustration que je pense que beaucoup
d'entreprises qui les ont assistés d'une
frustration quelconque c'est comme toi
avec vega n'est pas plate clair-matin
attachement aux valeurs
environnementales ce faire tu as marck
équipes ont donc été attaché à une cause
pour believe he mois écoutez je voulais
lancer mon troisième produit
les gars ça soit je travaille avec
compagnie ex nommé nouveau personnes
puis je m'assois avec avec eux au moment
du développement de produit puis son
corps dis moi combien de pays dit je
comprends beaucoup à dire lorsque dans
le fond voici ma formule comme un peu
comme une seule charge qui était quand
même un métier tu peux couper ton
produit de faire comme tout le monde
puis j'ai commencé à composer quand tu
dis tu peux couper les produits faire
comme tout le monde ce qui tuerait de ce
que dans l'industrie de suppléments sur
une pratique courante de faire ça c'est
malheureusement une pratique courante
effectivement fait que met-on méthode
achètent des suppléments de compagnie x
il ya des gens que ce soit diluée se
soit coupé avec white bull jusqu'en
panique cela ces compagnies en baisse et
des règlements quand juste le monde
clairement il ya des bonnes copines
supplément sur market mais je peux vous
dire qu'ils sur believe sa promesse
parce que je suis en contrôle
la formule que tout est analysé puis
publiquement analyse donc à ce moment là
que commence à se poser des questions
moi je pose des questions comprendre
qu'est ce qui se passe je suis je suis
un jeune aux dents saines c'est dans cet
environnement là des suppléments je
connais pas trop les gameplays maintien
on peut couper avec ces ingrédients là
ça va être cool et le corps du prix plus
je me rends compte de tout ça fit pas
avec qui je suis c'est pas en ligne avec
les valeurs que je prends dans les vip
je pourrais pas opérer lance dans ses
paramètres là donc je décide de quitter
j'abandonne un projet briest pendant
trois jours monde dans ma tête j'étais
tellement ça m'avait tellement frappé
heurter parce que j'ai été con
sommateurs de suppléments à 18 19 ans
qui dépasse et ça paye dans les
suppléments c'était 3 500 dollars par
mois
c'est vraiment quelque chose dans lequel
j'ai dépensé que je me sentais tellement
tellement heurter le jt comme ça ça se
peut pas que je me suis fait avoir toute
ma vie puis séchés paul seul en ce
moment si on a plein de consommateurs de
suppléments donc après trois jours de
réflexion où j'étais comme montrer je
peux tu vraiment quitté déjà fait cette
frustration à l'enm où je me suis dit
non je vais en faire ma mission de
redonner aux consommateurs excusez moi
pis d'amener de la transparence pour la
première fois dans une industrie qui en
avait grandement besoin donc de l'eau
est partie l'idée de believe sa promesse
de transparence de mettre des analyses
et qui sont publiées sur internet
de jouer la carte de l'intégrité et la
transparence des valeurs qui pour moi
sont juste part importante dans ma vie
donc de bâtir une business qui est en
ligne avec ce que c'est l'industrie qui
est checké réglementée par mettons santé
canada puis ce les truies supplément
dans le fond absolument la façon que ça
fonctionne je veux montrer que dans tout
simplement vous allez mieux comprendre
pourquoi c'est facile de toucher des
produits c'est qu'au canada pour vendre
des produits saverin npn dans le fond un
numéro de produit naturel donc tu
appliques avec une formule qui selon les
paramètres de santé canada est légal ça
veut dire que s'il formule une recette
de ton enfant exactement sont donc qu'il
ya certaines raisons qui ont des
paramètres très précis comme la caféine
tu peux pas avoir plus que 2 5 mg de
café dans un produit et bla bla bla pour
des milliers d'ingrédients donc se
présenta formule santé canada foccart
répondre à toutes ces exigences
exactement elle approuve te donne un
certificat de vente au canada donc
semaines numéro sur ton produit et une
main sur les étages on a tout simplement
mais santé canada vont pas prendre
chaque produit sur une étagère dans un
magasin x pour les analyser et on en est
on pas les ressources pour faire sur
deux ce serait une ultime perte de temps
pierre non par dessus la tête avec
l'industrie du cannabis en plus qui
s'est acheté leur sans parler de ce que
vivent des vies damman le même même
avant tout seuls n'y ont pas le temps
fort des des analyses de produits donc
qu'est ce qu'ils vont faire c'est une
fois de temps en temps par année ils
vont prendre les produits avec des
stimulants au hasard sur une étagère pis
vont analyser les stimulants qui à
l'intérieur pour celui qui a pas de
danger pour la santé des consommateurs
fait que la formule qui est soumise et
pas nécessairement ce qui va se
retrouver dans un sac en bowling
sottisier informés qu'ils seraient
soumises à santé canada kit analyser ce
qui nous inquiète c'est beau ça pétait
tablette c'est pas nécessairement ce que
les gens vont consommer non c'est débile
sims qui a pas de contrôle puis non
seulement sur mac leasing ça me met dans
la peau de protéines si je te dis
qu'elle 28 grammes de protéines dans mon
pot parcours par par porsche et parce
qu'il est en vie je décide de couper
cette protéine l'eau à 50 % avec un
magasin se verra pas la différence comme
le mato dextrine en multi connaît
vraiment ce il y aura pas d'impact sur
la santé mais peu dangereux cycle de
glucides qui voudraient une protéine
produits moins efficace pour savoir si
cela passe mais le succès qui vont tuer
créé 28 grammes de protéines ou 14 jours
marqués battre août
si vous remarquez zéro g de glucides
mais dans le fond il ya 14 grammes de
protéines de 14 mois qui fait que c'est
du mensonge
toulouse la fosse représentaient ces
justes d'enfants l'étiquette est pas et
pô juste exactement pis selon les
standards de santé canada je peux même
légalement être offre de ton étiquette
de vin pour ça de façon légale et moi
j'en ai un laboratoire de production et
je vous dis qu'il est au off 3 4%
je peux comprendre m -of 20% faut
vraiment vraiment que tu décides et
offre un clip sont imputées si tu es
capable de dormir le soir à étoffe les
bovins porcins pourquoi s'il veut pas 50
ou 60%
c'est sûr qu'à man et de la soif de
l'argent parce qu'elle est juste la
marge de profit à doba triple à chaque
photo c'est dans ce sens que tu le vends
au même prix c'est décalé en semaine on
dirait y en afrique m'a frappé dans ce
que tu disais puis à mon avis c'est un
peu dans les nerfs de l'entrepreneuriat
c'est de vouloir faire ta propre affaire
selon tes valeurs à toi tu es nous ici
ce qu'on a fait avec le studio c'était
de vouloir faire des conversations est
ce qu'on parle de ce qu'on veut lui
offrir le droit est le droit offrir la
chance à tout le monde de pouvoir venir
ici puis pas être régi par aucun par
aucun niveau de langage doit être régi
par aucun sujet que palois l'aborder
moyenne de temps et contraintes de temps
qu'on prenne le tout puis cette
frustration là dont tu parles
j'ai l'impression que comme tu dis ça
peut-être dans le nord de la décision de
faire ta propre chose en marge de ce qui
est déjà établie mais dont la tige tpr
obligé de partir à une entreprise sur
une frustration mais je pense que c'est
une solide base quelque chose qui
réellement tiens quand tu es frustré de
la cour je pense que ça mais ça fait
beaucoup de dégâts sur le feu comme un
métier ça pas besoin de naître d'une
free magritte et admettons tout avec les
causes environnementales d'une certaine
frustration c'est sur la façon qu'on
opère en tant qu'êtres humains dans le
monde points donc oui ça c'est lui c'est
plus dû chercher une solution j'imagine
cherche une solution à un problème
probablement un métier d'homme par
exemple qui opère en tant qu'artiste
c'est une forme d'entrepreneuriat je
pense qu aucune frustration quelconque
drive c'est plus mignonne cause
créativité dans un sens quand même un
peu ça le fiston sens que moi j'ai envie
de faire souffler que j'essaie de je
suis passionnée par la musique puis
j'essaie de crime d'opportunité et puis
de défense le plus possible outil c'est
que fait non c'est pas né d'une
frustration
peut-être juste la frustration des foies
de porc être tissé métisse ici mais
touche pas à pleyben je veux faire mon
propre projet tremblante issue probable
a pris pour jouer dans le projet d
autres exemples
bref à mon programme for peace voici
bouquet c'est fait ça peut être
peut-être cela suppose tration le sait
mais ce n'est pas vraiment une
en fait je pense que chaque bon
entrepreneur
chaque bon solo preneur comme doom
chaque bonne entreprise est née d'une
cause quelconque l'on tient également à
coeur il faut que cette cause de soi en
ligne avec ton échelle des valeurs
personnage parce que c'est super
important aussi la cgc moins que la
liberté c'est ma valeur la plus
importante la numéro 2 son intégrité je
pourrais pas être libres financièrement
en r1 arnaques en tous l'impression que
plus une entreprise est grosse plus
c'est difficile qu'à soi projet des
valeurs humaines comme ça je pense que
tous partout donc s'il est si les
dirigeants de cette entreprise là on
encore le contrôle la culture puis
princes en quarts puis et imprègne
l'importance des missions à l'intérieur
je pense que non je pense que tout peut
toujours roulé à ses droits mais qu'un
les valeurs de l'entreprise au début
était passé fort tous homos bastos qui
est assez solide ce qui le retient c'est
qu'un sas peur que l'arbre se met à
pousser croche un certain prix pentue
qui peut devenir une multinationale en
étant hyper droit moralement sans pour
autant tous les ans non parce que je
parle interne dans d'autres entreprises
donc c'est dur pour moi de le dire mais
si on est parti de deux livres dans mon
condo à un brain top trois au canada à
l'intérieur de quatre ans en gardant ses
valeurs la transparence mais on s'en
fout ios avec les mêmes valeurs que l'on
changerait absolument
mais quand on parle de multinationales
j'ai l'impression que ça arrive un
moment où est ce que c'est on se cachera
pas que ya cinq compagnies qui possèdent
toutes ces maisons quand tu voles
d'armes de line
puis j'ai l'impression que pour rentrer
dans cette espèce de ce qu'ils me la
faut qu éventuellement suivante puis une
fois que tu as vendu les valeurs
risquent de disparaître imagine mais
c'est sûr que si tu sais de le trône à
quelqu'un d'autre c'est surtout un
certain changement j'ai l'impression que
ce gars avec les multinationales les
portes du temps que tout ce qu'il n'y
ait trop gros est acheté par quelqu'un
qui sait encore exactement
oui mais aussi ses plus de monde - plus
ça devient une question de statistiques
de chiffres j'ai l'impression qu'ils
m'ont aussi demandé de rester humain de
rester en contact avec les gens pli les
clients et les consommateurs j'ai
l'impression qu'en qui berce tanina
traitement c'est sur l'année on veut
parce que j'ai pas l'impression que plus
c'est gros plus c'est comme acquis il
faut atteindre cet objectif lopy peu
importe la manière
en fait je dirais que souvent ça ça va
être vrai pour les compagnies qui sont
publiques parce qu'il faut qu'il rende
des comptes et aux investisseurs et aux
dirigeants alain terme donc le thé
présent danger de faire brasser un peu
vu que du doigt des comptes à plusieurs
personnes mais quand une compagnie
privée pitt encore le contrôle de la
culture des décisions qui qu'est ce
qu'on fait avec les profits je pense que
tu es moins à risque justement que cette
admission se dilue la traverse ce camp
quand ça a commencé à grossir et
simultanément de mon côté maton et le
studio et vegan les peuplades puis que
moi j'étais pas du tout y est pour faire
face à ce genre de croissance lâche
gestion là puis j'avais dans mes poches
ainsi l'horreur puis j'ai portée
capables de faire la distinction entre
mon travail puis quand tu travailles
s'arrêter
parce que j'avais pas du tout faite le
ce chemin et le géant menti je veux
qu'on en parle partout chez qui tous et
est arrivé puppy que tout est tenu des
problèmes par rapport à ça puisque ça tu
as réussi à trouver des solutions qui
moi m'ont aidé beaucoup une fois une
fois que j'ai écouté ton ton podcast au
skate en parle
moi personnellement j'ai perdu des
cheveux je perde des choses j'ai encore
des trous mes cheveux j'ai des trous
dans barbe si liés au stress lié à une
surcharge de gestion puis à un manque
complet de séparation de ma vie privée
ma vie personnelle puis ma vie
professionnelle il y avait eu aucune
limite aucune frontière d'autant plus
que j'étais en business avec mon
meilleur ami je tends business avec ma
blonde à ce temps là puis comme tout
souhaite devenez juste complètement flou
pis même pendant pendant des mois ça me
rendent fous mongueurs le tiche de jeu
devenait ça me prenait le thé chez nous
à cette heure alors que je disposais
justice les puis relaxés plus je pensais
des affaires du lendemain pour la job
the same same donner une boule dans le
ventre puis sam sam querrey de l'anxiété
ça criait de l'appréhension
je t'ai pas aux bâillements puis
j'aurais vraiment aimé ce à être au
courant de la possibilité dessus tout
c'est est arrivé ce truc ne raconte un
peu ton parcours dans ce tournoi
comment petit avec toute la croissance
de brive quelques une croissance très
rapide
comment s'est passée de ton côté
maintenant l'épisode 6 de n'ont pas de
cash par des crises de panique qui me
sont arrivées la prison que j'avais créé
pour pour moi même c'était un c'était un
peu spécial mais ensuite j'ai besoin
d'eux
j'ai invité qui s'appelle film mascotte
qui fait du pnr de la programmation
neurolinguistique y avait un aliment
qu'un peuple c'est quelqu'un que je
connais j'avais déjà fait des sessions
avec lui et je pense que quand commence
par faire ton échelle des valeurs en
premier lieu puis comme on parle tantôt
moi je sais que ma balle en numéro 1
c'est la liberté
la liberté financière aussi la liberté
d'avoir l'énergie de faire que ce que je
veux la liberté de pouvoir aller au gym
camps s'entendent c'est pas la liberté
au premier degré l'encensent voir
courrier ou sortir le mardi soir c'est
possible mais c'est vraiment la liberté
de prendre la place dans mon esprit pour
passer à avoir des idées faire les
choses que j'aime avec les gens que
j'aime la croissance des livres qu est
ce qui est arrivé c'est que ça s'est
tellement passé vite puis c'est la
business avait tellement besoin que je
sois présente tout le temps non
seulement le brun mais aussi on est en
train de partir en laboratoire j'ai
brimer ma valeur la liberté tellement
longtemps pour combler les besoins de
croissance de believe comment mener eric
fonctionnel amato est pile je me suis
partie du jeu partie du bureau m ennuie
c'était un lundi soir de la semaine
d'avant j'avais une semaine de travail
accompli je t'appartiens c'est un gros
rush de partir à pittsburgh voir un
manufacturier américain ensuite à l'est
chicago pendant deux jours tournée du
contenu avec un athlète j'étais revenu
au bureau jamais une semaine de fou puis
ma blonde est monté se posent à lui
signer - jours 6 heures une histoire
piété soir au bureau à blainville ont
disposé à montréal chez dans le jeu
comme d'habitude puis je me suis d'abord
descendu en charpie chantique mans c'est
mon cas un pompe et puis là je vous
parlais au téléphone puis une partie de
mon cerveau tu pensé à mon coeur qui
pompe et puis l'autre partie du cerveau
qui essaient de se déconcentrer
depuis par les ti pour oublier que monk
importe peu avant les jeux tht j'étais
même plus capable de parler ma blonde
fait juste pensé mon camping car est
tellement vite que je pense que j'ai
fait une crise et quand j'ai pris la
première sortie à montréal je viens me
chercher je suis capable de conduire le
stress avait tellement pris place dans
la vie que peu importe qu est ce que je
faisais y avait plus rien dans son
artiste et quand tu brilles m la chose
la plus importante pour toi sur ton
échelle des valeurs des fêtes c'est sûr
que ce soit quand tu mens un drap autour
de ta victoire finaz par étouffer psy
c'est ce qui m'est arrivé ici je me crée
une prison puis en même temps ça m'a
ouvert les yeux sur le fait qu'il
fallait que je change les trucs parce
que sur une base quotidienne choisi de
l'introspection
j'avais un journal et gratitude marche
il marquait toujours les choses pour
lesquelles j'étais reconnaissante si je
faisais les petites choses mais la
pierre en clair le coeur battant c'était
mon c'était mon téléphone de travail
parce que je n'avais pas pu faire de
distinction entre mes deux mondes comme
tu dis tantôt j'arrivais chez nous à 7 8
heures le soir je me faisais texte et
jusqu'à 11
je me réveille le matin et que j'avais
les textes à partir de 7h30 le matin
pourquoi parce que je t'aide à cette
dure au tchad différents dans business
puis quand on se rend ce texte dans les
groupes c est une fois de temps en temps
c'est des bonnes nouvelles mais souvent
c'est un problème à gauche à droite il
quand la business gros si tu travailles
avec tous les départements parce que je
suis opérateur apprécié par le business
y arrive plein de bobos puis ça me
laisse jamais c'était le samedi matin ce
samedi après midi samedi soir si tu vaux
super avec table on se prends ton
téléphone tous vos toilettes pour garder
tes messages clin d'oeil à trois
problèmes cndd soit au resto tu arrives
à table et plus la même personne qui
pense à ceux avec l'autre partie ton
cerveau qui essaie d'avoir une bonne
section l'amendé pendant le repos
tableau tandis qu'aurélie n'était pas
présente le tout y passa sur les
inscriptions fait que ça m'arrive et
tout le tintouin
puis je me suis jetée au djembé et puis
je faisais de cardio je reçois encore un
texte un problème sur mon téléphone
chose qui est courante en affaires c'est
quand même puis je me suis adapté est en
train de faire du vélo qui chantait mon
coeur partir la corse par vite pierre je
me suis acheté un téléphone de job puis
j'ai créé mon équipe je me suis dit que
j'ai tout donné trois années m'a
tellement ça fonctionne ça fonctionne
vraiment moins bien de mon côté voici je
me souviens qu'il faut pas avoir peur de
s'ouvrir discipline des fêtes de de
s'ouvrir par rapport à ça je pense au
contraire si c'est ça monte une certaine
force des capable de dire comment tu
tiens surtout à dire des employés puis
j'avais je vais leur respect de jeu par
par mon ardeur au travail et puis tout
le monde a accepté mon nouveau mode vip
tout le monde a respecté puis gégé qui
séparait les deux mon petit douter que
l'entrepreneuriat était fait produire un
certain moment de vue le stress que tu
vives et ses crimes
dans le fond je t'aime peut constituer
face parce que j'aimerais ça qui est une
conception qui est entrepreneur faut
qu'ils travaillent 24h 24 sans relâche
pi pi je vais je pense que c'est une des
conceptions mais tu penses à ta maman
crime dans le fond je préparais pour se
situe non jamais j'ai dit dès de ma
place en entrepreneuriat je pense que
qu'est ce qui m'est arrivé sic
ces quatre mois quelque chose convient
que ça paie la traversée du désert du
moins je l'appelle comme ça sur mon pote
pièce puis c'est le moment où tous les
clients thibault pour te faire connaître
tranquillement déjà la gatineau puis à
québec faire des démos des dents les jim
pour pour avoir des titres pour avoir
des ventes
je faisais mes dégustation produit moi
même pendant près d'un an et demi petit
cette période là et connaissant mal
phone parce que tu sais postwar une paix
afin de la semaine fait souvent dire non
c'est après passage obligé exactement ce
qui s'est passé ce qui est obligatoire
en attaque est peu importe la grosseur
de lempire que tu rebâtir mais la farce
et moi j'ai gardé cette mentalité le
plus importe la grosseur qu'on en attend
si je continue d'être dans ses mains de
cette lettre je pense que je continue
justement parce que j'étais quand
j'étais jeune je les dis tantôt gêné
gaspésie j'avais dit j'avais tellement
besoin
j'avais déjà en manque d'opportunités et
tout et tout figé puis j'ai vraiment eu
peur longtemps que que tout ça soit
juste un mirage donc je continue de
faire rouler la rouler le plus vite plus
fort possible qu'un message ça m'a
rattrapé une loi quand décidé de faire
ces secousses le puits de moins
travailler mais de travailler dans des
heures de travail normales mais tu en
avais tu pars premièrement qui sort un
effet négatif sur la business puis puis
finalement est ce que ça nous puisque
c'est un annuaire que ça change quelque
chose de ce que ça même améliorer la
situation
sauf la fête
ouais ouais puis le soir tard quand
j'arrive chez nous je suis à mon
téléphone puis j'en ai je sens que mon
téléphone personnel clôture jamais
problème c'est comment mon phone que
j'appelle ça c'est ma blonde cph s'est
déporté qui tu sais que je t'aime
[Rires]
n'ont fait que non parce que de m'ouvrir
à mon équipe ça m'a permis de me
rapprocher d'eux peut-être pas besoin
toujours mené à en tant que superman
depuis des mois je pensais qu'il fallait
toujours que j'avais ma cape de superman
depuis j'ai eu tellement longtemps
quelqu'un je les hôtes et finalement ils
ont vu qu'il y avait un être humain à
l'arrière d'être surpris je pense que
j'ai gagné
les employés général puis est ce que ton
équipe du tout vu déléguer davantage son
équipe ou pas nécessairement non parce
que les temps que je passais au bureau
ou du moins le temps que je pense à
travailler pour apporter à la maison ou
au bureau
j'étais encore plus productif parce que
le temps que je coupais maintenant grâce
à ma nouvelle façon de faire ça me
libérer beaucoup d'espoir matin en jeu
j'étais mieux j'ai juste eu plus de
bonne humeur j'étais moins stressé
j'avais démerder j'avais plus de clarté
d'esprit
donc non je pense que ça a juste bien
fait petit je pense que si si vous vivez
des épisodes de stress peut importe
c'est quoi c'est vraiment nous asseoir
et d'essayer de trouver le coeur battant
nature c'est souvent on essaie dit
technique à gauche à droite vous je me
couche plus tôt vous que je fasse un
journal de gaytitude faut que tu dis
mais au bout de la ligne c'est cette
chose là aussi si vous touchez pas
vraiment aucun problème qui va puis six
mois
ces petites choses le 6 et 10 il faut il
faut que je fasse mon journal il faut
que je fasse ici parce que je te
présente parce que lui qu'il fallait pas
qu'elle va te faire [ __ ] stressé plus
qui est amené de positif le fait qu t'es
fou comme si vraiment de trouver
l'équilibré
c'est pas facile pour mettre le doigt
dessus qu'il faut se poser les vraies
questions manisaspor que autour de vous
une personne super toxiques qui nuit
considérablement à votre vie à chaque
fois que vous text câline vous stressez
provisionnement aucune raison ça peut
être votre ça peut être vraiment dit
tout à fait le même
faut pas avoir peur de faire face à ça
parce que sinon seront jamais bien
mentalement que je pense que c'était
jamais bien ce serait jamais houle
moi je pense que là
la chose qui a fait la plus grande
différence pour moi puis j'ai eu un
déclic un peu comme comme toi tu au jim
moi je cours beaucoup outils puis je
courais avec nous nos montres
intelligentes maintenant le moindrement
je voulais de la musique ou que je t'ai
hodges maintenant avec mon set n'est pas
loin de moins je recevais quelque chose
passe à vibrer sur mon poignet puis même
si je me disais c'est pas grave j'ai pas
besoin de réponses en ce moment parce
que j'étais au jam mais crise je pense
et puis ça m'arrivait d'arrêter mon
training plus de bonheur pour faire un
nom mais le faut je m'inquiète de ce
dont je m'occupe de ça maintenant je
peux jouer faire que j'allais prendre
mon ciel pleure je n'ai fini puis comme
je me suis dit ça peut pas être ça peut
pas être ce je me suis ramené à nos
années de natation qu'on faisait
ou est ce que quand tu es dans piscine
ton scellier dans les stades vestiaire
que sa beauté de la vie or rien mais un
acte imagine dessus exadata le prouve
maintenant 0 coach puis aux rays et jean
reno faut jamais prendre un appel un
vestiaire et même tu sais qui c'est d'or
du club des calices est pas là pour les
bonnes raisons
là je me suis remis en tête ce puis je
me suis dit ok il ya certaines affaires
dans ma vie qui sont vraiment plus
importante que le succès du genou
l'autre de mes entreprises va donc puis
puis quand j'ai fait ce switch là que
j'ai commencé à dire mettons mois les
traîner c'est une zone que personne ne
veut il ya personne qui rentre dans
citoyens grecs - les fans semaine c'est
une zone où est ce que personne vaut
parce que c'est ma zone de faille
semaine où est ce que toutes les offres
de toute façon et aucun aucun client
aucun fournisseur aucun wever qui va
s'attendre que tu répondes un dimanche
mais moi je me mettait la pression de
répondent les dimanches et même sur
quelqu'un qui nous écrivaient pour louer
un studio de podcasts je laissais le
messages non lus jusqu'au lundi matin
humaine parce que personne qui va
s'attendre
esneu et que je réponde le samedi ou
dimanche
mais quand c'est dès que les classes
effet si que ça m'a fait du bien
maintenant mon cell quand je courais est
en mode avion ayant rien qui rentrent
je mets de l'amuser dati puis ma montée
même pu connecter à mon style ma montée
juste indépendante de mon seulement puis
ce sera la fête nos styles différents
mais je gare ma vie dans mon dans juste
mon bien être
pis si on sort l'entrepreneuriat pour
pour les gens qui nous écoutent qui sont
entrepreneurs qui j'ai l'impression que
ce truc là parce que tout le monde tu
d'etoudi à gérer si tout le monde a dû
d'être dispo vrai qu'il ya quelqu'un qui
est juste un ciel qui est juste pour les
emmys tout le monde d'études à gérer que
ce soit avec la job ou à l'erreur
d'avoir ces périodes là où est-ce que
c'est inaccessible pour personnes qui
pendant ton cercle personnel je pense
que c'est nécessaire
ben oui si nécessaire de se protéger
jeudi vous avez quel âge j'ai juste pour
du queens of 29-28 fait qu on a tous
vécu ici le secondaire on n'avait pas de
téléphone tout à fait ça a été j'ai eu
un blackberry genre cégep trône oui moi
aussi j'habite et 7 ans j'ai fait quand
on est versé et coûte moins cher et qui
s'échappe au cégep cinq heures et
pendant 5 aux tab
ces presses à tabac on a vécu
justement le site secondaire passer ses
tarifs chez vous peut plus vraiment de
lien de communication à moins qu'ils
soient sûrs et mécène qui font qu'on a
véhiculé les deux séparations puis si je
me souviens en secondaire 5 de conduire
dans l'auto avec mon mp3 branché dans
l'exil hier puis d'être dans ma tête
souvent c'est pourquoi faire appel tout
en ajoutant un facteur audric maintenant
qu'on a le téléphone dans nos mains puis
on a un monde de possibilités qu'on
monte de choses qu'on peut faire mais on
sent obligé tout le temps faire quelque
chose
puis on se laisse plus de place à
réfléchir à la créativité justement si
c'est vraiment ça descend on n'aurait
pas passé un camp dix ans j'ai juste
pour une lan mais maintenant bluetooth
dans l'auto sur soi des médias parlent
tout le temps jamais le seul en mai mais
je tenterai de me répondre à des
messages
mais ce concept le dain de rien faire
j'ai l'impression qu'ils aient vraiment
difficile à accepter dans un monde où
est ce que le succès tout en valoriser
pitt ces jeux là on est là on parle ans
par l'entreprise mais tombe livre son
histoire instinct success story l'été
puis je dis ce que tu parles de liberté
financière ce que tu partie de je veux
dire tout ça c'est quand même lié au
succès ce cas m lié à à à un travail
énorme des efforts massifs des sommes
investies
puis j'ai l'impression que autant le
message peut être travaille fort mais en
même temps tu dis ouah mais aussi ses
carrés de rien faire
on dirait que c'est difficile de saisir
croit-il c'est quoi les messages tout et
tout et rien qui tend en fait tout est
tandis que dans son dray dans en
discordance dans ce qu'on entend dans
les messages qu'on entend dans le monde
dans lequel on existe c'est dur en
tabarnak de faire le lien c'est de fait
de faire est de réaliser c'est quoi
réellement qu'on veut faire c'est de
prendre du temps pour rien faire au
chalet oui je comprends tu y mets en
même temps crise tu trempolin arrêt
pouvoir rien faire au chalet si t'as pas
un chalet puisse tout est pas mis en
position pour pouvoir rien faire si on
en parlait on a parlé avec avec est à
dire justement hier où est ce que moi
j'ai l'impression que puis je critique
rien de ce qu'on dit je critique c'est
juste que j'essaie de me mettre dans ma
perspective du rire je suis privilégié
même de pouvoir penser à ne rien faire
j'ai l'impression que c'est le genre de
commentaires qui viennent un endroit
privilégié puis c'est pas tout le monde
qui sortit pas tout le monde que la
drive de start in compagnie suppléments
que l'éthique de travail de certaines
compagnies supplément qui est l'éthique
de travail de travailler 12 heures par
jour que le gouffre que le goût de faire
cesser ce puits on dirait que dans la
société auquel on visse ultra valoriser
le succès mais depuis que les gens qui
ont du succès des wham est aussi
important de ne rien faire anti pilotes
et lot des coups dessus petit doigt me
crise j'aimerais seulement rien faire ou
chalets mais en ce moment je peux
capable d'arriver je vois capable
d'arriver je travaille pour une
compagnie qui me sous payent gpad j'ai
pas eu l'occasion j'ai pas eu le témoin
si je t'ai pas né dans une famille
nantie je serai pas j'aurais pas fait le
parcours scolaire que j'ai fait
j'aurais pas eu les opportunités que
j'ai eu puis j'ai l'impression que c'est
ça même s'il jouera c'est dur de sa
blessure mais c'est quelque chose que le
straw go vraiment à essayer de
comprendre quel est le message
le plus universel possible qu'ils
s'adressent pas juste à des gens qui ont
le privilège et je pense que le message
et on attend toutes sortes de messages
témoins qui paraissent contradictoires
différents messages vont s'appliquer
vont toucher différentes personnes
quelqu'un qui s'en met vraiment trop ses
épaules comme toi tu étais avant mais
qui s'abritent complément sa santé
mentale
le message est dans le droit de de
prendre sa relaxe pi2 de faire attention
à sa santé mentale sans se sentir
coupable que le droit système est un
message qui va être pertinent pour toi
mais il joue ya des gens qui il déjà que
le message des pistes importantes celles
vip d'accomplir d'affaires puis
travaillé fort des gens que si ces
messages le qui ont pourtant besoin
d'entendre mais que tu peux être
pertinent pour eux dans leur vie tu sais
pas si on est pas tous pareils il peut
ne pas tous besoin d'entendre le même
message pour nous avec
je ne sais pas s'il ya un message
universel t mais je trouve que c'est
bien dit donne-moi sens que c'est facile
de se laisser emporter par les médias
sociaux puis avoir cette pression
performance là parce que le succès est
tellement bien démontré son intérêt mais
c'était ça paraît tellement bien avoir
du succès sur instagram pitre et nous on
est la maison comparez notre chapitre 22
avec la page couverture de tout le monde
mais ça c'est bien au fond de tulle
c'est quand la dernière fois que vous
avez mis sur papier qu'est ce qui vous
rend réellement
qu'est ce qui fonctionne pas dans ma vie
en ce moment qui sait que c'est quoi les
stresseurs que je capable d'éliminer en
ce moment dans ma vie c'est parce qu'ils
y en a pas de message universel le seul
bon message c'est celui qui vient de ton
cup celui que tu es capable de mettre
sur papier zéro qui voici qui je suis en
tant qu'être humain voici des choses qui
vont me rendre heureux
puis voici ce qui fonctionne pas dans ma
vie en ce moment qu'est ce que je peux
faire pour éliminer les choses qui
fonctionnent pas c'est sûr que ça va
faire en sorte que tu voudras bien que
timide heureux peu importe de quoi les
hôtes ont l'air c'est du caca dessus
marque red steel moi ça m'a inspiré
je les ai trouvés inspirant ça m'a
motivé ça ma peau angoisse pas sortie
des loges mais il faut que je travaille
autant que lui il faut que je performe
il faut que si ça m'a juste motivé à
m'améliorer qui a optimisé des affaires
et puis j'étais juste positif mais j'ai
des gens qui nous écrivent pour réagir
aux podcasts pièce qui écoute qui est
des gens qui ont écrit joël mais le
soldat marc fit est dangereux il est
accepté ça met une pression sur le monde
qui sait ça fait que les gens c'est ce
qui s'appelle avoir à dire avoir des
effets pervers sur la santé mentale du
monde puis je comprends je suis certain
que quelqu'un ait des gens qui
s'arrêtent cet effet le met sa poussette
et fellous sur moitié fonction
messagerie dessus hilti pervers il le
prêter pour moi tu es si tu comprends
mais j'écoutais l'épisode avec mark
pétrie marque c'est quelqu'un que je
connais très très bien et marc picard
est ce que je me trompe - assez
longtemps pitié encore
ça fait un bout j'ai pris mes marques
mais souvent juste comme des des genres
des trucs pour d'optimisation le
connaissent pas bien puis la personne
que j'ai entendu ce que j'écoutais
l'épisode techniquement puis si si la
personne que je connais ses marques
le travail sur son échelle vie au
travail est clairement fait que c'est
normal que n'importe qui puisse comparer
lui à travers les villes c'est vraiment
obligé numéro un mondial tout le monde a
sa propre échelle si vous écoutez le
podcast en ce moment vous n'êtes pas
trop sur certaines feuilles de papier où
certains surfent au téléphone puis
faites là votre chef est la vôtre et
celle des valeurs c'est comme cela tous
repartis à la mode des vies que votre en
europe mais si tullow giocante au parc
puis qu'on a rencontré une fille pic à
teruel fréquentes telles golan attention
dessus pedigree il gagna une grosse
business nanan pillet qui est ça a pris
du temps parce que tu es tellement pas
précisé quelle part aux normes et si
c'était juste que la fille disait t on
se réclame depuis un boot métier céderai
jamais sérieux parce que lui tille
d'après entrepreneurs sa business avant
tupina l'anapi je sais que toi tu es tu
bien d'un bain pas vraiment métier je
comprends qu est-il lui c'est vraiment
important la business puis pense juste à
sopi peut-être que les valeurs à lui
fait peut-être que justement lui ces
valeurs d entretenir
une relation amoureuse avec quelqu'un
est vraiment plus beau de tous de toute
évidence que ça business puis si si pour
toi c'est ce que tu veux ça concorde
roja mais elle s'est fait que je dis pas
vu de moi mais ton jeu prioriserait les
relations humaines avant la définissent
ça c'est mon échelle de valeur à moi est
ce que je condamne ces gars là parce
qu'il fait ce nom il ya le droit ce qui
le rend heureux
fin mai mais c'est eto'o j'imagine que
ta blonde qui a été fait un sweat
shadyac contente années ce type arrive
je peux être instruite je dois te fais
un switch des eaux qui mettent après 8
heures je travail plein les yeux aussi
j'habite à montréal maintenant et mon
bureau et à bléville donc une fois temps
en temps je travaille à maison puis je
me suis amené man je travaille et je
pense qu'au mois de novembre dernier ma
blonde met chaque année parce qu'elle
est étudiante puis à l'étude eu beaucoup
fait que mais toujours à la porte en
même temps que je travaille généralement
et plastique un module ça m'a tellement
vallée de maintenant quand je travaille
sur quelque chose qui me passionnait sur
quelque chose qui me passionne encore
cette mission ils ont depuis quand on
parle de stress on parle aussi l'entrée
des leafs et c'est quelque chose que
j'adore puisque toupie je suis
extrêmement bien l'entrepreneuriat c'est
magnifique pour moi c'est une des plus
belles choses qui m'est arrivé cette
mission elle est super importante dans
le continent et puis j'adore mes
employés jadot mais quelqu'un m'a dit ça
m'a vraiment ouvert les yeux mais quand
j'avais leur pied de l'extérieur du
moins parce que c'est comme si je me
centaine d'inscriptions difficile mais
c'est bon qu'est ce que disait tantôt
par rapport à un tir un couple de
vraiment mettre son échelle des valeurs
chacun à bord ma maison pit pit compare
ici je trouve resto justement avec ma
blonde ya deux semaines à québec
ils ont parlé chacun et l'autre de noter
celle des valeurs ses pieds tout se
connecter puis en tant que couple n'est
pas juste l'échelle des valeurs il y
aussi les langages l'amour qui sont
super important si vous avez déjà tenté
- les cinq gars de lamothe-goas
exactement donc il ya cinq langage
qu'ils sont c'est quoi ça
mais l'alliance parfaite
ils sont parce que ses moyens c'est un
excellent sujet fait d'hommes il ya cinq
façons d'être aimé excellent qui s'est
ajoutée de démontrer aussi ton amour je
me siècle l'auteur mais livre un très
bon donc les cinq façons selon l'auteur
sont les suivantes les cadeaux donc ça
peut être n'importe quoi du kinder
surprise daubresse les tiffany les
services donc aller à l'épicerie
nettoyage etc
les modeler monde attention world of
wisdom kimche fière de toi piste
encourage tout était beau t'es bon
c'était quoi le deuxième s'cusez moi
les cadeaux les services que nous
servait les mots d'encouragement en
encouragements les attentes qualité puis
l'affection démontra démonstration
physique démonstration physique
affection limite donc souvent on est on
est guidé par part de langage de l'amour
et si on n'y met pas son papier du moins
qu'on se compose pour la question à
savoir qu'est-ce qu'on comment on aime
se faire aimer si on pose pas la
question notre partenaire souvent envoyé
des mails autres personnes de la façon
qu'on aime la façon qu'on aime et pilar
ça va créer des grues des gros clash en
amour qui vont faire en sorte que la
plupart des gens priorise de méthode sur
les exactement donc si toi en amour un
bon signe moi je les y ramener des gros
cadeau ce samedi comment sa relation à
donnant des cadeaux pour comme preuve
d'amour mais peut-être que cette
personne là si son cinquième mariage
d'amour un bras la main mais ouais ça
mais c'était c'est l'ironie la fête
c'est quand même à linverse puis
justement j'en donne pas de cadeau non
mais non mais c'est vrai me dis moi
mettons là j'avais j'avais lu sa piste
et je m'étais analyse a fêté moi c'est
sûr que ces chars de services pitt en
qualité sur les deux affaires que
j'aime le plus c'est mettons cuisiner
pour mas blanc nous c'est aller à
l'épicerie pour deux temps puis de
passer du bon temps ensemble
moi j'ai pas besoin de me faire dire que
je suis bon j'ai pas besoin de me faire
toucher de me faire donner de
l'affection physique j'ai crissement pas
besoin de cadeaux s'est fait que c'était
mes deux petits puis là pour cet
analyste droit mais finalement pas mal
comme ça que j'aime au site et puis
c'est vraiment pas tout le monde pour
mon expérience c'est vraiment pas tout
le monde qui veut les même langage que
les miens c'est important de se poser
ces questions là c'est vraiment
fascinant parce que moi je trouve que ça
fonctionne vraiment plus quand tu
t'assieds avec mon avec ton partenaire
avec temps parlent de ce défaut est une
réalisation des rockies pour ceux qu'on
a des accrochages les faux quand
j'arrive du travail aussi ça parce que
je fais quelque chose qui je crois est
un signe d'amour qui pour toi ne
représente pas la montre fait que non
seulement fascinant way to die côté
langage de l'amour
[Rires]
je suis fier de toi continue vraiment un
tir de sentir un support puis je
t'aiderai l'affection effectif capable
de peau vraiment passé de temps pendant
deux ou trois semaines et c'est de
tendre quel type qui de carnac de 0,6
que metric temps qualité ça fait partie
ocado world of wisdom ouais je pense que
ça va les résidences que c'est fait mais
je les ai pu les 5e fraîchement
apparaître le fait que ses yeux c'est
dur à dire mais tant de qualités je
pense qu'ils la réalité pour un crime
que c'est important pour moi ce que je
veux qu'on parle un peu parce que
dernièrement j'ai vu passer puis je veux
avoir ton opinion sur ce je vais passer
sur les réseaux sociaux et qui est comme
un espèce de mouvement
[Musique]
anti supplément qui se promènent sur le
sociaux au sens où les suppléments sont
survalorisées maintenant dans une dans
la vie de tous les jours parce qu'on
voit assez sur les réseaux sociaux
est ce que c'est quelque chose que tu
que tu vois au quotidien est ce que
c'est quelque chose qui était au courant
et n'ont absolument pas une surprise
pour moi ok d'enfance et c'est comme de
quoi mettons là là les suppléments de
protéines et au final n'en a pas
vraiment besoin puisque c'est comme une
jarre de façon à des compagnies de faire
de l'argent dont on en parlait au début
tu es juste quête du monde qui cotent
les les suppléments on se rend compte
que définitivement une question
monétaire derrière ce mets mais c'est
quoi moi personnellement j'ai toujours
pris des suppléments depuis que je
m'entraîne c'est que ce soit des bc ce
soit de la protéine j'ai toujours pris
parce que rapidement on m'a dit qu'il
fallait que j'en prenne maintenant j'ai
jamais checker plus que ce j'ai jamais
vu si vraiment un apport en protéines
après mais training était nécessaire ce
que je sais c'est que quand j'en prenais
souvent ben premièrement j'avais moins
envie de tomber dans le meck d'autres
suite après mon training puis
deuxièmement je récupérerai plus
rapidement ça c'est mon expérience qui
m'ont appris mais n'a que quinze ans on
les fait par rapport à ça j'imagine que
tout est au courant de ces choses
maintenant dans le mot supplément il ya
aussi supplée pts et ça vient
supplémenté un certain mon avis donc
c'est sûr que si tu manges au mcdo deux
fois par jour puis tout en train de pots
de bonheur
nous savons être content verra rien oui
tu dépenses pas ton argent en bonne
place mais un athlète comme toi qui fais
attention qu'est ce qu'ils mangent plus
qui crie un certaine carence en douceur
de vitamines ou à ses menées sans aucun
doute les suppléments fond de sens donc
c'est là pour supplémenter une bonne
hygiène
c'est sûr si t'as pas une bonne hygiène
de vie se sent complètement rien on sait
vraiment ce bon point il par rapport
celui qui kahn qui en a besoin
puis quitte à ne pas besoin de temps
comme je dis ce qu'ils font pas
attention à leur nutrition de fonds 6
qui vont pas nécessairement au jam qui
est qui qui qui qui passe parce que tu
peux avoir des carences en différentes
vitamines ça dépend du type de
supplément si vous êtes ici sur la chose
mais règle générale si te prêtes tu dois
je dors pas bien ne serait pas tensions
entre la nutrition tu fais pas un peu
d'activité physique
je pense que tu as dit eu des gros
problèmes à gérer à régler avant de te
lancer dans les suppléments tissu si la
maison est en feu
il faut éteindre le feu ont commencé à
construire des étages dessus dans le
temps ce serait ce la première mais oui
mais est-ce que s'adresse vraiment aux
gens qu'ils s'entraînent énormément
nous prenons connaissance oui est ce qu
est ce que c'est possible parce que je
pense que c'est cela ma principale est
ce que ce serait possible de mettons
prendre tous ces suppléments là sous
forme de nourriture
moi je sais que ce serait collé sma plus
compliqué c'est une job à temps plein et
c'est ça que le monde se rendent pas
compte exact maillage débarque et met
sur les marchés nous avons deux
tendances en alimentation humaine ton
poulet aux james et se fait pas pousser
mes légumes derrière chez nous puis je
sais pas comme un hacker était comme
commençons mais mes légumes sont ces
légumes qu'on achète à l'épicerie sont
arrosés avec quel genre de souvent et on
peut y ont beaucoup moins de
un de la guesse minéraux d'un moindre
niveau de la viande
si tu prends pas des viandes sauvages
des ddd vianne biologique
tu seras passante et à manger des
zéniths et à manger des animaux malades
non christine on entend parler longtemps
de pensée que tu peux tout avoir notre
alimentation en 2020
je pense que c'est complètement insensé
à moins que tu enfiles joe batory le
branding autour des suppléments s'il ya
des sacs de suppléments que ces genres y
est à holque de succès xtreme power
si ces gens ont vu leur compte et on
dirait que vous mangez ce pigeon pour
devenir le luis et le team exagéré par
un public qui est très mince qui veut
prendre la masca pin-up souvent c'est
juste des poches de sucre nettement
spotify mais pourtant si c'est un peu ça
s'est moins vendu believe mènent depuis
qu'ils m'envoient des trucs si c'est
vraiment de la bombe
si je meurs vers suppléments que j'ai
pris de toute ma vie mais on va pas se
cacher que tu vas au jam et ont le même
temps je veux pas que tu trembles par
rapport à ça je vais prendre sur moi de
dire seul mais y était d'un magasin très
populaire de suppléments qui existe au
québec qui qui vend un petit peu cette
idée là de comme devenir une baisse là
que tu vois des gens qui se plaignent un
chèque de protéines après le djembé que
tout ce qu'ils font mais c'est juste
prendre du poids même pis si comme ce
n'est un gros bide mais des gros bras
plus tu dis moi mais ça c'est pas
qu'est-ce que pourquoi est-ce qu'on en
cours à quoi est ce que me faire de
l'argent sur ce qui veut qui veut
devenir le gros gars qui fait pas de
cardio qui fait juste dégaine étions
trop ça branding de marbre mais écouter
mais c'est ce monde là qu'ils achètent
parce que j'ai un peu con toi sur ce
point là a besoin d'un sens que je pense
que c'est toi qui regarde la situation
de cette personne neutre à vente il de
la vie à toi sans ce qui peut-être que
cette personne lequel se trouve un peu
corpulente maintenant mais là je veux
vraiment pas sandrine qui fait des gones
mais qui fait jaser rocard diop qui se
pointent son sens à son chèque de poids
tout abri pc comme cette check notre
continue mais je pense que cette
personne là peut-être que c'est son
objectif fish ma voix fera clairement
vos bus avec le fitness et ça rend
possible - bon chrétien niveau santé
j'en conviens que ce soit ait fuit le
cadre est clair et tout et tout de la
dire que c'est aussi bon peut-être peau
mais si c'est bon pour son moral se sont
ainsi sommés reste mais je comprends ton
pour comme te dis niveau santé je pense
quand même que telle sur deux raisons
pour lesquelles tout à faire du sport
mais somme que la santé reste ça devrait
être la première je devrais juste que si
ta motivation et esthétique à faire du
sport il quelque chose d'un peu peur
voire d' ben moi je pense qu'en 2020
pour la plupart du monde c'est
esthétiquement et je sais mais autre
pour les filles maison est beau et puis
cela se sait la pression sociale qui on
peut parler de tout ça parce que tu vas
au jam puis je pense que c'est l'autre
jour je demande aux parquets qu'avec
deux mondes jeune fille qui est fait est
fait limitation du ce et du mouvement
des jam de qom c'est ce ces gens le
mouvement que tu vois tout le monde
fabriqué comme au final les prophéties
en 2006 est la seule à faire puis meidum
tu marques un excellent point par
rapport au fitness puis on peut tomber
un petit peu dans cette conversation le
comme tu dis si derrière l'idée d'aller
au jam mieux pas d'être ou de faire de
l'activité physique est pas l'idée
d'être en santé dans un problème j'ai
l'impression qu'ils ont un problème
fondamental dans la société parce que si
ce qui met la seule enfant parce que
oui si tu vois mettons faire le
mouvement que je vienne faire la passe
que tu vas voir ce que j'ai fait sur
instagram ce qui va en découler sais que
tu vas être plus en santé c'est surtout
vrai plus en santé en faisant ce camp
crise en rien ce site définitif mais
j'ai pas l'impression que ta bonne place
quand même si on compare ce que vous
venez de dire avec l'entrepreneuriat ce
serait la même chose que quelqu'un qui
sépare en affaires pour faire de
l'argent
oui ça faisait quelque chose à faire de
l'argent tu aurais pu le même feu je
pense que les filles où les gars qui
vont au gym pour des raisons esthétiques
pour aller d'un bord du poignet ou sous
avoir plus confiance en soi pour m xy
morceaux de linge souvent ces personnes
une fois qu'ils vont tomber en coupe où
ils vont atteindre leur but ils vont
arrêter au moins lui vaut perdre le goût
d'aller aux jo parce qu'une récente
l'émission est pas transcrit quand ils
vous pourrez transcender être en chef
devient effets secondaires de tes
missions principales - rome à être à
celle ci aussi relatif tu peux être en
santé sans or le beach boys oui oui ça
pour ça je vais je vais quelque chose
qui m'a qui m'a marqué le stéphanie et
misfits qui est legend sujet du cc qui a
loupé à le publier un commentaire qu'a
leurs sucs et sur les sur son physique
fixe entre aïn qui est en sus par chip
qui a eu à le publier sur son sur son
instagram jeu je le trouvais que misfits
un jim de grosses torche qui est ça
c'est le nom de son poste à la s'est
fait assez fait écrire ce sur sa page
facebook
c'est un gars alexandre bureau nicolas
c'est dans l'air du temps
question si tout vas jim pour gross
torche qui veulent devenir mince mais
que la propriétaire à la chute d'un
lutteur sumo professionnels est-ce que
c'est plus crédible thématique si en
plus tu as perez misfat se serait fait
juste à la première phrase il ya
tellement de faccini de body chez c'est
la pire chose à chaque mot ja remettons
tout va à saint jans cappel smith par
saint jean comme moi si je recherche
nutritionnelle sportif va prendre un
gros tonnes marc d'obèses c'est sûr ça
fonctionne
olfa people
ça c'est le dernier hashtag ce cette
espèce de 10 des là que la santé est
égale à une shape
c'est complètement stupide tandja par
les ccc vraiment puis rapport avec le
point de croix où est-ce qu'on est
problématique en termes de comment on
voit la fitness comme en voit l'activité
physique en ce moment je pense que je
pense qu'on a un problème tu l'as bien
dit c'est pas susciter un bol si c'est
la raison pour laquelle tu le fais mais
j'ai l'impression qu'on est tombé
là-dedans par les réseaux sociaux parce
qu'on voit sur internet puis c'est
problématique mais il faut sortir de
suez où des commentaires de même même si
ça avait elle a s'entraîne quatre fois
par semaine
mais comme toutes les semaines et en
shape le genre oui est plus grosse que
moi mettons le may cry secours des
marathons au pistil comme ça rien à voir
mais du moment que tu commentes
l'apparence physique de quelqu'un était
dans l'erreur en partant vous un peu
importe je pense que ce que dit mais ça
j'ai l'impression que si le problème est
aussi que si tu commentes l'apparence
physique de quelqu'un ce secteur le même
temps vers le titre
oui mais si moi je suivais une influence
ce genre n'est certes à g qui a eu une
immense perte de foot puis mais comme
dans sa bio c'est qu'ils 95 livres dans
depuis c'est jordi avant après tout le
temps thiam année j'ai fait me semble
que ce discours le de focus et le
l'entraînement puis l'activité physique
sur la perte de poids et ironie et oui
ça devrait pas être ce genre ça sent
mieux dans sa peau
six ans plus en santé ça sent de
meilleure humeur 6
l'entraînement lui donne un cercle
social ces entraînements lui donne de
toutes sortes d'aspects positifs mais il
faut que c'est sur la perte de poids
avec vous dans ce sens là même même
chose dont on parle tant tout nouveau
puisque léger coup c'est sur papier ses
quinze jours de physique depuis quinze
jours d'entraînement pitié de vous
suivre pour t'en as physique l'appui on
a chacun notre propre idéologie du corps
parfait pour nous-mêmes je pense que
c'est de se respecter soi-même tout
simplement puis s'essuie les hashtags
tout ce que tu vas passer des fesses et
des cuisses comme ceux affectés c'est
rien de réaliste lit c'est facile c'est
une fille c'est la comparaison en 2020
était jeudi surtout une file élégance
qu'on parle aussi mais je pense que
c'est tout à fait légaux avoir un
dashboard sans colle je pense pas mais
les filles souvent ça va être les
physiques pour sa part très très jeune
fausse il faut protéger son esprit
vraiment cessé mais bon tu dois te déjà
fait dix finissent jamais fait de
compétition mais j'ai déjà eu un
physique de compétition pour leur foi -
enfin - seul enfant qu'est ce qui motive
à force je sais pas c'était dessus le
dépassement personnel de mettons qu'on
essaie de réfléchir à 7 ou le
dépassement personnel de toit en verre
toi-même c'était dessus un objectif
physique cd dessus des autres déploie un
objectif physique ça c'est clair
si je me suis jamais dit je veux poser x
où je veux avoir là dessus je pense que
c'était juste le dépassement me prouver
à moi même que je capable de vraiment
accomplir quelque chose ça m'a tellement
donné confiance quand j'étais arrivé
dans le monde entrepreunarial parce que
ça faisait 3 1 le fond que sais je suis
je suivais mon plat ni menteur pu monter
jaleo jim deux fois par jour puis tout
ce simple petit je faisais pas de
compétition objectivement je le fais ça
me faisait plaisir de vivre ma vie comme
ça pour moi ce n'est pas une corvée
je pense que quand il fait des choses
dans la vie qui sont pas une corvée pitt
aime profondément bel effet secondaire
dessous c'est une réussite quelconque
peu importe qu est ce que tu fais pour
moi en affaires c'était le succès rapide
de beaux livres parce que la cause me
tient à coeur
quand c'était le fitness bien que ce qui
me tenait à coeur c'était le dépassement
moi même ça se passerait donc je suppose
t est-ce que dans le monde que tu
côtoyaient dans ce lot parce que je suis
con par la cad
sébastien calvet ci dessous elle a
trouvé que cet univers là était somme
toute assez malsain et métiers de des
gens qui côtoyait l'espèce de toujours
dépassement des verts une visée
esthétique tais toi tu as tu vécu ça tu
as tu vu des gens comme sedan dans ce
milieu qui qui avaient des troubles avec
ce jeu de la paix des troubles
alimentaires personnes qui pouvaient
avoir certains troubles alimentaires
c'est sûr que 4 de la baignade dans le
monde la compétition il faut soit deux
prochains je pense qu'elle a béni un peu
plus dans le superficiel autour de la
cause de la compétition je te mets moins
n'ont pas récemment je pense que j'étais
entouré justement d'athlètes de pointe
quelques jours photo lemercier ou qui
vous laissent dépasser donc non ça a
vraiment aidé de deux mois voir moi-même
qui j'ai jamais été un jeu jamais
vraiment tomber dans la maladie de la
comparaison à link je me suis toujours
comparé à moi même parce que ce que je
vais devenir qu'est ce que je voulais
accomplir pied je pense qu on l amérique
meilleure personne avec qui se comparer
c'est la seule façon de rester sain
d'esprit
si fou comment une chose ces mots
l'activité physique
je trouve ce ultra important puis mon
background sportif as vraiment fort j'ai
les personnes que je suis m'a appris
tellement d'affaires que j'applique à
chaque jour je touche je pense que tout
le monde devrait faire du parti puis je
pense qu'on aurait bougé
c'est fou comment une chose positive
n'importe quoi à l'extrême peut devenir
mécène étiez vous vraiment faire
attention de ne pas tomber dans donc un
extrême mais c'est clair que là c'est
même un certain point humaine
même mon parcours de natation métaux
l'indicé ball dans l'extrême sud
pourrait au final ce que ce que c'est
mon plafond mais ton s'est jamais posée
l'impulsion de sa vie de bonheur lundi
quand même pas se mesurer postiers
quatre mois c'est sûr exacte et un
plafond quand même mais ça reste que que
tu t'entraînes comme un défoncé si on
parlait des arts une manière le titre du
monde fondée à rome en amateur même que
ça tient le centre de leur vie min qui
délaissent leurs familles parce que jean
wahl 6e samedi perd place d'alex mes
enfants je prends mon vélo entre les
deux hommes pendant 12 heures du meti la
question après ça c'était tu es heureux
ou des misérables à 4 nages et était
dessus tu étais pas misérable la misère
c'est toujours la question est ce que je
le fais pour moi même parce que je le
fais pour les noirs je pense que si tu
fais pour moi même si 37 jours tu
t'arrêtes pose cette question que je
sois toujours moi je pense qu'on devrait
le faire chaque semaine puis c'est quand
la dernière fois que vous êtes pauvres
réel en termes de types de même de
reconnaissance générale ces canadiens
faut que vous êtes arrêté dans une
journée pour vous dire la chance qu'on
avait détenu au québec détenteur et
d'opportunités c'est nomme prends ta
ville pyrénéenne de guerre civile en
syrie le seraient sur kate devrait pas
des guéguerres gauche à droite n'en
porte ou universitaire s'est étonné dans
ces paramètres on a la chance
d'accueillir nos fruits chez ge d'avoir
un pc à 2000 dollars par mois
cayenne pandémie mondiale puis on trouve
quand même se plaint excuse moi parce
qu'on n'a pas la classe mais tu vois
assez de faire des discussions de même
régulièrement ce genre de choses qu'on
qu'on se répète qu'ils comptent
rencontrer l'autre c'est la pandémie
comme style on est bien ici ne sera pas
de mon sens c'est le pc d'ailleurs s'est
basé sur une musique canadienne même à
vancouver le 2 mille piastres
effectivement moins 25 cl c'est le 2004
à vancouver 2010 à vancouver ils
connaissent ma - ils représentent
vraiment moins qu'au québec lé ton loyer
demandé c'est plus cher ici à 2000
dollars
tout le monde paie son appart avec ce
minimum 10 nous qui avons une compagnie
manufacturière essaie de trouver des
employés qui mon frère un peu cheap au
moins 14 et 17 dollars dollars quand tu
parles de pcu à 2000
ok c'est pas de l'argent est m c'est un
certain temps certains des films sinon
il ya beaucoup de gens qui voudront je
supporte notre avis les habitudes aussi
que je dois y ait des gens que ça fait
quatre mois qui font rien là-dedans sera
pas facile pour eux de retourner au
travail
mais tout ça pour dire que la la je
trouve que l on devrait s'asseoir une
faute en piètre connaissance et si on
parlait un autre niveau puis si on est
né avec toutes nos marbre on est en
santé on a la vision on est capables de
se parler en ce moment c'est ce que tout
le monde que cette chanson dans la bible
souvent on est dans le trafic d'urnes et
stressé parce que on va de cinq minutes
de retard mais on se rend pas compte de
la chance qu'on a de chance là aussi je
pense que c'est important de s'arrêter
dans une journée puis vraiment de faire
face à la réalité l'ont livré ma chance
dans la ville est bon conseil si moi je
le fais vraiment on le fait des
personnes le fasse je dresse pour des
niaiseries 27 fois par jour mais si je
vous en parle en ce moment parce que je
prends temps de passer puis avant de
rentrer si je te demande tout en tout
cas ce que je pensais que tu as dit ce
matin on se fiche de mon chantier m'est
arrivé nizri de l'impôt temps de
relativiser vraiment une très importante
puis deux puis après ce une détresse ou
une difficulté ou une peine est il
valable quand même la chance que je
remette dire à quelqu'un t'a de l'apn
rouaix may est monté en plus d'à peine 4
ou non mais c'est peut-être relativiser
relativiser aussi par rapport à pas
nécessairement aux autres personnes a
par rapport à qu'est ce que ça
représente dans la dre viennent pas de
recul sur une situation assez marque
justement tu sais quand je me suis
séparé de ses marques mais crient famine
10 mais dites là tu dis mais dit toi
qu'on est pas mal infini puis que je dis
dans quelques mots c'est derrière toi
puis après me donner une autre cause ma
bd qui médit la vie c'est pas d'artiste
après le procès sur un sur un de ces
postes là mais maudit la vie humaine
c'est pas d'attendre que l'orage passe
mais c'est d'apprendre à danser dans la
pluie j'ai fait pire comme de fès volent
tuent relativise doute mennecy ainsi 13
à quelque chose qui degré semaine que de
tout ça un texto le même prendre une
seconde quand tu leur soit pour
relativiser à quel point ces mini pc
rien python serait de s'en aller
automatiquement absolument réputé droit
de 10 de vivre des peines qui des
stresseurs mais je pense que darwin ce
qui me faisait la plupart des choses qui
nous font stressé dans une journée sont
absolument nulle ouais quand vraiment au
printemps puis l'hôte exercices à faire
c'est que je repense à toutes les
affaires qui sont stressés témoin
certaine période de ma vie où est ce que
pendant trois jours mettant mon anus
faisait seul sait quand un mâle de cure
à cause d'une affaire de ces exilés je
rentrerai pas dans les détails
alors pour ceux qui écoutent en audio
j'ai fait le signe du rire mais
maintenant c'est cet été ces périodes là
les mettons de trois jours qui pendant
les pendant que ça arrive tu envie de
mourir
plamen décalé d'un an je me dit elle
admettons que ça se serait passé comme
la pire situation que j'aurais pu
arriver là dessus aujourd'hui je réussis
ça n'aurait rien changé
pendant trois jours même je me serais
arraché à temps à cause de suite pour
finalement syrien devant une voiture à
l'islande se réalise que tu peux tu
paniques pour des affaires qui valent
pas pu répéter c'est bon tu que tu dis
parce que je pense qu'on t'a finesse
mentale par rapport à ceux un peu comme
en allemand clip au jam à force de
s'entraîner c'est la même chose pourquoi
pas ce que tu fais de l'introspection
petite pause se pose des questions à
chaque jour à savoir qu'est ce que ça
vous stresse mais pourquoi patrick est
ce que je vais faire la prochaine fois
ça va se présenter dans ma vie je pense
que quand tu fais toujours ces exercices
là mon étui est tellement tellement
tellement que tu viens tu viens
difficile à déranger mais je pense que
si on fait peu d'introspection dans la
vie on se fait brasser comme une feuille
dans le vin et puis on est toujours en
mode action réaction donc c'est vraiment
important de toujours s'asseoir à maison
puis de se poser des questions si vous
le faites pas chaque soir au moins de le
faire chaque semaine c'est vraiment
important insiste on se pose pas cette
question et le moins que je pense 1
c'est la fameuse phrase les quelques les
profs d'université 19ème session le
parvis d'entente et on va tous avant la
noël gagne péter comme j'avais
d'ailleurs le pascal [ __ ] et c'est vrai
on va tous avant noël en vie peu importe
ce qui arrive même stephen king
précédente affectation
pigeât travaille fort fait des multiples
mais après si c'est pas la fin du monde
on va tout mais semaine je pense que ça
serait quelque chose qu'on devrait les
buy va vous donner tout le monde on va
se rendre à noël c'est vrai genre c'est
quoi le pire qui peut arriver même où
ces seuls
c'est ce soir que tu sais il y en eut
que le pire qui peuvent arriver c'est
quand même été une balle dans toy tout
finir en taule le titre c'est le pire
qui peut arriver je comprends mais pau
pour mettons des gens qui sont pas d'en
créer un outil ou à l'inversé c'est quoi
le pays et qui peut arriver mais le père
qui peut arriver c'est que ces cultures
est à noël éventuel manque des proches
c'est éventuellement tu penseras même
put semaine c'est un trou de pau dira ce
pour penser à ce centre que sa femme a
pas juste le dire à voix haute comme ça
m'a pas non mais je sais comment ça sur
l'homme aux 6 md frist oui je me sens
j'espère que je pense avoir fait la même
chose pour les gens qui s'inspirent les
auditeurs et je veux être un support ou
d'une question posée mais avant c'est
d'ailleurs j'en ai 50 pour dire aux gens
d'aller sur itunes de ses 5 étoiles
[Rires]
ça serait pas d'audace en
entrepreneuriat les atouts ça change et
efficace et c'est cool que c'est sûr que
c'est sûr que non en fait ben c'est sûr
que non difficile à dire mais je pense
pas ce que ça l'a fait c'est qui
rapidement je suis venu travailleurs
autonomes pour la première fois c'est la
première chose qui m'est arrivé il a
travailleurs autonomes
attends tu t'arrêtes de s'orienter dans
l'année dlp un épisode vous étiez pas
sous la régie des finances de la grèce
dont les sorties sur la pelouse était la
mine d'or d'opportunités exact fait moi
je suis devenu travailleur autonome par
le fait même jeu devenu entrepreneur
parce que parce que tu gères tu tomberas
tf1 puis fil en aiguille vega niveau
platine et fait l'année guillon ne
sert-elle podcast je suis un peu tombé à
reculons un peu ce mélo maintenant que
je les fait une fois j'ai comme eu la
piqûre
on dirait puis on en reparlera plus tard
après le podcast mais d'autres projets
que j'ai en tête qui me tracasse qui me
donne envie de l'essayer
on dirait que je suis comme on dirait
qu'une fois que j'ai réalisé que c'était
accessible devenir entrepreneur que
c'était quelque chose que je pouvais
faire
j'ai quand même fait ok non là il ya
quelques semaines des possibilité une
fois que tu réalises qui était pas
obligé d'avoir un patron petit peu tous
en même lettre comme on dirait qu'après
c'est plein de possibilités mais si je
l'avais jamais vu j'avais jamais ouvert
sa fenêtre avant avant aude et puis je
suis tombé dedans un peu par hasard au
parlement que tu serais pas là
aujourd'hui trois bleus manquent non la
réponse est probablement non prends ma
que j'aurai fini ma maîtrise que
j'aurais fait que j'aurais à appliquer
dans l'air une place qui a besoin d'un
rédacteur des trucs comme ça j'aurai
travaillé je m'en étais heureux aussi
mais j'aurais pas été entrepreneur puis
j'aurai j'aurais juste parce que je
refuserai jamais dit que c'était une
possibilité mais tu y es tu remets ton
méthodes avaient voulu écrire ces
maisons qui veut écrire publier c'est
une forme d'entrepreneuriat mais je
pense pas que je pense pas si je pense
aux mariniers var ce n'est pas ce qui me
sera alignée je m'en vais retravailler
peut-être dans une jatte ont une des
idées que j'avais c'était genre une
boîte de pub en est un de ceux qui un
rédacteur le kiki reda qui rédigent des
genres de tagline des trucs comme
solange une boîte de pub ça j'aurais
fait sur wii mais c'est fou comment que
l'entrepreneuriat au pis les ors sais
c'est quasiment la même affaire
c'est vrai si la créativité si rien
n'est pressé y ait quelque chose parce
que là j'ai plein air est d'accord écrit
quelque chose sont écrites et green
business
elle existe à pau maintenant elles
existent comme le concept you rien puis
l'oeil de quelque chose avec ton ta tête
tu écris quelque chose économique est
encore plein de projets petit jeu des
activités toujours active et c'est
oui c'est vrai que c'est c'est de la
créativité sedif et ça se manifeste
différemment les bus même les valeurs
des fois différente la créativité
clairement si vous êtes deux personnes
qui ont un grand besoin de créativité à
combler vous le conflit via votre
podcast qui est une forme
d'entrepreneuriat mais tous avec vega
même plateau avec la musique donc oui
c'est vraiment quelque chose
aymen merci infiniment d'être nue ou
est-ce qu'ils ont depuis qu'est ce qu'on
fait on achète quoi le mont pas de quel
journal un entrepreneur à les suivre
tout faire si l'entrepreneuriat vous
intéresser la gestion de j'ai beaucoup
d'étudiants qui me coûte qui m'écrit ça
les a sont à l'école savent pas trop
quoi faire puis j'ai une question pour m
pour finir de quesques ckoi lit les
types de personnes premièrement parce
que l'entrepreneur et ex et pour tout le
monde mais temps c'est bon ce que tu
disais tantôt parce que si je m'étais de
la lumière sur le fait que c'est
accessible à tout le monde
de là à dire que c'est pour tout le
monde je pense vraiment potes ça
s'apprend mercer un arsenal d'outils en
tout cas je pense mais une personnalité
prêtre est un type de prentiss
l'impression pour être pour être prêt
d'entrée pas assez pour mener d'éditer
d'enfer être être leader c'est dans ce
foutu à une pénalité de leigh dans une
impression mais cette fois c'est
intéressant parce que je pense que le
besoin de performances le besoin de
flash en 2020 de 20 sur les médias
sociaux
ça vient de les gommer ça nous pousse à
vouloir être numéro beaucoup que les
influences qui veut dire qu'ils sont
entrepreneurs était la personne numéro
36 chez facebook fait parlement a plus
qu'à peine numéro un dans le monde dans
une compagnie effectif je pense que
c'était quelqu'un qui fait de
l'introspection encore on en a parlé
pendant plus parce que le podcast qui se
posent des questions à savoir c'est quoi
mes forces et mes faiblesses dans vie si
parmi les forces ya peu certaines
capacités de leadership tout jamais fait
de leadership dans tv puis c'était très
récemment un grand sens de créativité où
il fait exactement peut-être par du
travail où tu as parlé longuement entre
jamais un bon entrepreneur donc tu es tu
peux tu peux mettre un pied dans l'eau
mais je pense vraiment pas que c'est
fait pour tout le monde puis le monde
voit le résultat final ils vont aller
sur instagram soins audi r8 sol à coup
sûr les fans y en a plein qui me disent
ce crime j'ai pas choisi bonnes
industries j'aurais dû une ancienne
copine supplément au site
lebron james p 30 millions par année
avec un ballon mais elle habite rillieux
est devenu six avaient sérieusement de
hasard mais je me think qui disait cela
dit si elle a un sens
l'entrepreneuriat in entre on en parle
et puis apparemment décidé mettons pour
des des amis des ânes de tout le temps
qui est le monde à sa famille saison qui
ça fait 30 ans cet entrepreneur dû
demander conseil à elle qui à 22 ans il
ya un vrai mentor garde a le soutien
dans l
puis à 10 est il justement tous les
influenceurs elle beaucoup qui par des
bandes pitts mai puis à 6 pas valorisées
de faire ça mais c'est pas pour tout le
monde c'est parce qu'ils puissent pas
tout le monde qui qui qui va être
heureux doit être bien là dedans puis ça
a l'air beau l'inflation les frais en
sus que ça brent qui met lui de trouver
la chose qui a rendu heureux mais toi
c'est coin tu sais je pense que le non
non non pas pas de cela c'est surtout
les influenceurs il y en a plein qui
vont lancer leur brendle un jour lancé
deux ou trois tee-shirts puis après
traumat entendra plus parler d'eux
immense qu'est ce qu'ils oublient eux
avant de lancer ça c'est la marque
psychologique cette défaite le volet
c'est un as well as pas de faux pas de
tels noms je pense qu'ils ont peu de
temps peut on peut tous l'essayer mais
je pense que avant de l'essayer c'est
bien de se connaître tout savoir s'est
réellement fait pour toi ou du moins en
connaissant ses forces et faiblesses est
associé avec quelqu'un qui comprend ce
qui blesse on va faire en sorte que le
projet plus de chances du site mais de
penser que
d'être l'idole de l'entreprise sa
retraite une partie plaisir ça va être
la chose a pu fondre de ta vie tu sais
ça fait un peu ça avec les ex-candidats
dodge thomas et oui c'est tout le monde
veut pas c'est son truc ce sens le cpo
105 nécessairement savoir exactement où
s'en aller ou qu'est ce qui est vraiment
il faut savoir que tu es comment il est
allé tranquillement entre jeudi la
compagnie des plus sûrs jolie quand on
prétend proposer l'opportunité qui était
super bien fait viennent compenser les
faiblesses que toi logistique emeline
seins demain logistique production et
ses rêves ou d'un complice pour ça que
le projet fonctionne super bien parce
que tu es capable de compléter force
avec les stars a décidé de lancer au top
de blue juste parce qu'il sort de dix
ans la pression de quelque chose ce soit
qui leur fait pression sur qu'il
assemble ben oui petit jeu connaissent
pas bien yann piat le prix qui est avec
toi pour les aider dans leur business de
coaching en sortant puis en fait de quoi
être super bon mais les gars étaient des
jeunes c'est ça exode des jeunes il
faisait déjà soeurs elles payent ils
sont jeunes ils avaient déjà voté oui
c'est le même j'aime et je continue il
s'agira aussi mais j'ai du respect pour
deco comme j'avais orange ou kid six
mois cette ville et au genre m'intéresse
pas aux réserves autochtones en gaspésie
facteurs déterminent la vie des français
c'est dans le fond c'est celui apporté
par mal à faire ça serait d'essayer de
l'anapi lui il se connaît assez peu sa
box pour ceux qui veulent piquer date
c'est cool pareille fête merci man pipi
dessus nous a fait plein de plaques pour
notre podcast mais les suppléments les
moeurs comment j'ai pris merci
j'apprécie merci les boss black c'est
par l'agression n'oublie pas de laisser
un commentaire écrit ça prend 32
secondes à botha a été une seule
nourriture pour 15 personnes